YouTube tips the first 15 seconds make
compelling content burst oh [ __ ]
start off with something that will
immediately grab attention stop by the
morning to you laddies
make it clear what your video is about
early on some viewers aren't confused
about what they're watching I don't even
know what this video is gonna be about I
never know what the video is going to be
about I this this video is about watch
time tease the rest of the videos so the
audience is intrigued to see where you
take them can take you out for the best
time of your goddamn life you click
videos before but you have not clicked
this video look at my eyes and tell me
that you will never click away I'm gonna
make you feel nice I'm gonna feel it
make it feel safe I'm gonna touch you
like no other person has touched can I
say that share your channel branding
later a flashy intro may be cool but
it's not the star of the video god damn
it I need a flashy intro cue the flashy
intro you son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that was good intro while this
YouTube vlog is really informative
it teaches youtubers how to get better
how come there's nothing about watch
time kenny misspell it what do you mean
watch time pewdiepie so for those of you
who don't know watch time is YouTube's
new new little baby it's like [ __ ] views
watch time is where it's at you gotta
have people watching your video for as
long as possible you get more promotion
which means more abuse better ads which
means more money
watch time it's the [ __ ] bomb if you
want to make it on YouTube these days
just make long ass videos [ __ ] any type
of pacing quality and none of that [ __ ]
that get up get the [ __ ] out quality I
told you I told you I don't want you get
I never had to say that you want to make
it on YouTube these day you gotta have
watch time and if you don't know what
watch time is it's basically you just
got to make long ass [ __ ] videos [ __ ]
editing them [ __ ] having any kind of
pacing slime it all out there watch time
that'll get you promotion it'll make you
a bum ass youtuber and you can buy your
next Lambo you're welcome for the tips
why did YouTube not say this on their
YouTube blog there's literally nothing
about this I found out this last week
YouTube what my channel has been dying
for the longest time why did no one tell
me this you know I would do anything
YouTube why did no one tell me this but
you don't believe me let's have a look
alright
alright Shh let's have it let's have a
look or just shut the [ __ ] about my
glasses alright let's go to youtube
gaming no no no no not that one no one
uses that [ __ ] let's go to YouTube's
gaming channel now you and me are gonna
count how many videos all on the YouTube
gaming promotion page is less than 10
minutes alright okay no no no oh we got
one oh wait it's my video
it's my shitty video okay well no no no
no no no
no I didn't watch that one I didn't
watch that one no yes
oh it's me again no no no no no no no no
no yes oh [ __ ] it's me again
now videos be longer than 10 minutes
used to be banned from YouTube all right
I remember when that was the thing you
had to unlock special features just to
be allowed to do that [ __ ]
now YouTube one see to upload more than
10 minutes and they don't even tell me
about it if your video is longer than 10
minutes that basically means you can put
you get better ads and you can put ads
in between the video which means you'll
make more money and you know what I'm
not gonna shame anyone for that I do the
same [ __ ] if I could bother to talk for
10 minutes that's way too long thank you
very much I already want to do anything
else but being here trust me I feel the
same way now the thing though it's like
you look at people's channels and you
just see like barely hitting the limit
and you you see the switch happening
like at a certain point all right where
is it here there are like three minutes
and then the moment of realization just
kicked in be like [ __ ] I need more ad
revenue four months ago they're all ten
now they're all ten now baby don't you
worry about it I'm gonna come back to
this listen I'm not trying to shame
anyone all right I would have done the
same he funds somebody would [ __ ]
told me on the YouTube blog that I
follow with every detail god damn it and
everyone does this all right I don't
I joked about this before and everyone
got super passive-aggressive towards me
like I got a family to support peeled
you got a prop [ __ ] problem with that
do your own videos I don't care I don't
care don't try and justify it to me but
what about videos that are playing out
that are well-written that have effort
into it like sketches and animation and
anything but my content what about those
people are you telling me those people's
videos aren't worth our time I think
it's the opposite those people's videos
are worth our time because they respect
our time I assume this was added as a
way to combat all the clickbait and [ __ ]
like that so if you click on a video and
then you find that well it didn't
actually [ __ ] the cow you'll click out
but really what this does is it takes
away from people that actually spend a
lot of time with every minute of their
video let's let's have a little look all
right you guys tweeted me this video of
jazz
listen everyone's gonna be like YouTube
drama pretty pie everyone sent this
video my friend Jack all right let's see
what Jack did what what way D Jack Jack
what the [ __ ] are you doing oh my god
Jack what are you doing
well played you Irish bastard
well played all right listen I don't
have the time YouTube
stop trying to be TV that's like Super
Mario trying to be Luigi that's like T
Martin trying to be syndicate that's
like 30pi trying to be filthy Frank
that's like Pokemon trying to be Digimon
you two stop trying to be TV for [ __ ]
sake actually I don't care I don't know
why I'm making this video doesn't matter
I'm just getting into here leave a like
if you enjoyed watching hit subscribe to
come abroad today and I'll see you bros
in another video and as always stay off
you thought I was gonna end the video
there [ __ ] you I need like this video to
be 10 minutes or else it's them I'm not
gonna do it it's not gonna do [ __ ] so
I'm gonna go play pokemon go I'm
actually just gonna go and take a [ __ ]
I'm not actually I'm not going outside
I'm just gonna hope that there's some
Pokemon that will appear even though I'm
not moving
you